ce sont des prises de vue d'une beauté
exceptionnelle
hiver comme été voici à quoi ressemble
les parois du massif du mont blanc
un privilège pour les pilotes qui vole
en montagne et ce jour-là à villepreux
ils sont deux à partager leurs
expériences avec l'assistance
l'occasion de rappeler notamment
l'hostilité des montagnes une fois la
tête dans les nuages ne serait-ce que la
proximité de la paroisse l'altitude à
laquelle vol l'avion
le manque d'oxygène aussi le lait puis
les instabilités verticale qui peuvent
quelquefois dans certaines situations
s'avérer dangereuse donc ça nécessite
des précautions avant de rentrer dans
les dents les dans les vallées
glaciaires à villepreux cette conférence
organisée par l'association audace
s'inscrit dans une programmation plus
large autour de l'aviation avec
notamment une exposition photo à la
mairie à la médiathèque jusqu'au 24 mai
prochain ça permet donc à la fois d'être
dans le culturel au sens de la culture
scientifique mais aussi d'être dans une
continuer scié par continuité par
rapport à l'enseignement à la pédagogie
donc on rentre on voit comment avec des
projets comme ça on rentre complètement
dans une boucle qui est informative
plaisir mais aussi qui est sur quelque
chose qui est dehors de l'enseignement
de l'information pour les jeunes et ça
c'est très important pour nous
la médiathèque de villepreux accueillera
une nouvelle conférence en octobre
prochain autour du tourisme spatial une
conférence qui s'inscrira cette fois ci
dans le programme de la semaine de la
science